The biggest problem I have with having the
entirety of human knowledge at my fingertips
anywhere I go is that it’s NOT QUITE FAST
ENOUGH.
Surrender your mysteries to me, internet!!!
Hello out there my fellow wireless human beings,
Julian here for DNews.
Radio waves have changed how we communicate.
When Guglielmo Marconi sent his first transatlantic
transmission in 1901, it sparked a revolution.
Suddenly information could be sent anywhere,
no strings or wires attached.
Mastery of radio waves has brought us entertainment,
kept us in touch with space probes, and, most
importantly to me, made the internet accessible
everywhere.
Of course, there are limits to how much data
wireless communications can carry, and that’s
why we still use fiber optic cables to send
data in bulk across oceans.
Fiber optics suffer less interference, have
extremely low latency (or lag, for my gamers
out there), and have achieved data rates of
1 petabit per second.
That’s well over 3 MILLION times faster
than the wifi in my house…
I’m going to have to call my internet provider.
Typical fiber optic systems are more in the
10 to 40 Gigabit per second range though,
which is still absurdly fast, 10 to 40 times
faster than the cat5 ethernet cables in your
home can handle.
And now scientists at USC have figured out
how to match those speeds with radio waves.
They’ve transmitted 32 Gigabits per second
by sending multiple radio beams through a
spiral phase plate that twisted them into
orthogonal helical structures.
If you don’t think that’s the coolest
thing ever then we can’t be friends.
The same team has used a similar trick to
transmit over 2.5 terabits per second using
light beams, but those don’t have the same
robustness to deal with obstacles that longer
radio waves have.
To put the speed in perspective, 32 Gigabits
per second is 30 times faster than LTE wireless,
it’s fast enough to transmit 10 hour-and-a-half
HD movies in a second.
That’s every episode of Seinfeld ever in
4.5 seconds.
In HD.
Think of all the joy this will bring to the
world!
Right now it’s only been successfully used
at a distance of a little over 8 feet.
Future research will work to extend the range
and may one day be applied to speed up cellular
systems and bring your 4G LTE phones up to
actual 4G.
So if Android comes out with a phone that’s
exclusively on a faster network will that
be enough to make the apple pickers jump ship?
Probably not, but Ross Everrett explains the
psychology of fanboys and how to break the
cycle in this episode of DNews.
What other miracle of technology just isn’t
good enough for you?
Let us know what little extra nudge your world
needs that would make your life easier in
the comments.
For me, it’s a pillow that turns my brain
off.
Get on it, science!
Until then, I’ll see you next time on DNews.